E aí
[Música]
e quando as pessoas te olham numa
cadeira de rodas e vem cumprimentar você
geralmente elas não imaginam que você
não mexe nem as mãos que é o meu caso
então muitas pessoas vêm
estendem a mão falando um vai dar pode
ser um beijo com
crianças com senhores Mulheres sempre
deu certo um alguns homens me Complicado
assim quando as pessoas vejam alguém
numa cadeira de rodas e que não pode
mexer nem os braços que é o meu caso eu
mexo só o ombro EA cabeça é elas logo o
meu isso é a pior coisa que pode
acontecer com uma pessoa nessa vida aí
para uma cadeira de rodas muitas pessoas
inclusive já ouvi falar várias vezes eu
prefiro morrer do que ficar nessa
situação de uma cadeira de rodas eu
entendo essas pessoas eu entrei no mesmo
e se mexer levantar o braço levantar a
perna mexer os dedos os movimentos mexeu
o corpo é a coisa mais linda que a gente
tem na vida é é a verdadeira riqueza
talvez exista só uma coisa mais
importante do que isso que a gente tenha
de riqueza e eu vou chegar lá
e eu hoje em dia sou muito observador eu
gosto de ver as pessoas
e se abraçando andando fazendo todo tipo
de atividade Eu também fazia todo tipo
de atividade eu jogava bola eu corria eu
tocava violão e alguns anos atrás eu caí
de um muro e eu tive uma lesão completa
no nível das e quatro e eu fiquei
tetraplégico na hora eu fiquei
paraplégica
ko5 Smith ele perdeu todos os movimentos
do corpo a sensibilidade
eu poderia estar aqui contando várias
histórias desses anos todos que eu tô na
cadeira de rodas
é mas quando você ver uma pessoa na
cadeira de rodas como eu disse
você olhando os seus movimentos você
podendo andar você poderia fazer tanta
coisa você logo compara e você fala eu
tô no lucro
ficar tetraplégico
Essa é uma das coisas mais difíceis que
existem nessa queda eu perdi todos os
movimentos do meu corpo é como se você
tentar se apertar o botão para acender a
luz só que o fio tá cortado você pode
apertar mil vezes que a luz não vai
acender a mesma coisa que eu tentar
levantar o braço Eu costumo dizer que a
Como se eu tivesse nos filmes tem muita
areia movediça a maioria das pessoas
morrem nos filmes na areia movediça como
se eu penso É como se eu tivesse até o
pescoço já quase lá me afogando e me
encontraram me salvaram mas a lama secou
completamente como um concreto então eu
tento me mexer eu tenho eu tento até
hoje né Parece que em algum momento eu
vou voltar a me mexer mas não eu nunca
consegui me mexer nem um pouco e para
falar a verdade
ninguém no mundo
e voltou Hangar não existe cura para
sequelas deixadas por uma lesão medular
porque a a a medula é um fio menor que
um fio de cabelo
responsável por todos os movimentos do
seu corpo
sensibilidade controle dos órgãos e uma
vez isso comprometido desistir nada na
medicina que seja capaz de
deixar como era antes só aquela frase
voltou a andar ela não existe E aí
quando você fica tetraplégico que é o
meu caso você abre seus olhos para um
novo universo o universo onde você pode
ter cadeiras que te deixam em pé Êxodo
esqueletos que te fazem voltar andar de
uma certa forma
cadeira de todas as cores
motorizadas eu tenho uma também que eu
posso me mexer com o queixo ou joystick
que vai até o Oi e aí você apresentado a
terapeutas psicólogas fonoaudiólogas
fisiatra os melhores medicamentos
existe tudo menos a cura ainda não
existe e aí você falar o cara tá aí tá
paraplégico ele pode contar as histórias
dele eu posso contar muitas histórias
Mas eu vi aqui hoje muito mais para
agradecer a segunda grande riqueza que
nós temos na vida como eu disse são os
movimentos e hoje em dia só apaixonado
está olhando as pessoas a primeira
grande riqueza que nós temos é a nossa
mente é o nosso cérebro é um presente
tão grandioso que ele é um suficiente
para gente notar que nunca ninguém vai
ser melhor nem pior do que a gente
e a gente tem um presente
grandioso e ele define como vão ser os
percursos da nossa vida e o que
aconteceu comigo
e de certa forma
exigiu uma uma aceitação eu percebi na
hora que eu ia ficar tetraplégico para o
resto da vida para o resto da vida muita
gente não concorda comigo eu sei mas eu
aceitei eu falei é para o resto da vida
não tem nada na medicina hoje que te
possa me curar eu vou viver da maneira
que eu tô foram seis meses no hospital
passei por ataque cardíaco
respirador eletrônico
sair do hospital voltei para o mesmo
planeta terra e se eu pudesse dizer qual
foi a primeira grande lição que eu tive
foi o agradecimento às pessoas
É porque quando eu cair eu tava lá
Deixado Para a morte se eu fosse
qualquer outro tipo de animal na
natureza
iriam me abandonar mesmo uma mãe com
filhote chega o momento que instinto
fala mais alto e você é deixado ali para
virar comida mesmo na natureza e se eu
tô todos esses anos numa cadeira de
rodas É porque quando eu cair teve
pessoas que estudaram para saber como me
socorrer como me tratar no hospital como
seria minha vida dali para frente
ensinar os meus pais a terem os cuidados
de fisioterapia de medicação e tudo isso
que envolve
a mente humana vocês me deixarem aqui um
sanduíche meio pertinho de mim eu vou
morrer de fome porque eu não consigo
alcançar eu não consigo comer então O
que eu tenho mais
agradecer Essas são as pessoas que eu tô
vivo até hoje é por causa das pessoas
eu e essa minha aceitação ela me
permitiu de uma forma muito intensa
começar do zero em vários sentidos
assim a Sexualidade minha masculinidade
por exemplo eu
aceitando a situação me abrir para a
possibilidade de saber se eu seria o
homem da vida de alguém que alguém iria
gostar de mim
da maneira como eu estava na maneira
como eu estou aqui Provavelmente vou
ficar o prazer você descobre de várias
maneiras pelo pelo pelo falar pelo
escutar pelo toque pelo cheiro existem
obviamente vários produtos no mercado
acessórios os hormônios eu não sou
deficiente de hormônio Eu ainda tenho os
meus hormônios que que me causam
sensações de prazer teve uma teve uma
vez num grupo de tetraplégicos que eu
sou
você pode tetraplégicos que as pessoas
ficaram horrorizados assim Surgiu uma
baita discussão quando eu disse que a
minha sexualidade de hoje não estou
mexendo nos últimos anos é muito maior
assim como trazer do que quando eu ainda
me mechia e as pessoas como isso pode
acontecer como é isso é aceitação se
você vive no passado o vídeo Na
expectativa do Futuro você vai chegar em
lugar nenhum porque essas coisas existem
existe só um momento no momento não
existe o que fazer ou você aceita ou
tudo vai ficar difícil dali para frente
você pensa que só fica tetraplégica
difícil não depois disso é que vem a
parte chata vou te ver pelado vou te dar
comida que escovar o dente vamos fazer
brincadeiras que você pegar sua mão
colocar em qualquer lugar tirarem fotos
e fica aprender a conviver em sociedade
novamente e sem aceitação todos esses
caminhos e a muito difícil então eu
falei muito de movimento na minha
opinião a segunda maior riqueza Que Nós
seres humanos podemos ter Depois da
nossa mente é eu perdi todos os
movimentos não todas porque tudo é
comparação eu vi pessoas com menos
movimentos do que eu por aí mas a vida é
cheia de movimentos então o meu
agradecimento pelas pessoas me leva a
falar como uma mensagem final mesmo você
tem a sua mente para trabalhar todas as
dificuldades que você tem na sua vida e
assim como os movimentos que eu perdi
Existem os movimentos da vida a vida
está em constante movimento não é só
esperar o mundo Teletubbies onde tudo
vai ser lindo não há tristezas
dificuldades da vida elas são tempero da
felicidade e vice-versa então a pergunta
que eu deixo para vocês é qual vai ser o
seu próximo movimento que você Oi vida
eu tô tetraplégico eu perdi o disse uma
das piores coisas que se pode acontecer
na vida de alguém mas a aceitação me
levou a descobrir o mundo maravilhoso
sim maravilhoso e eu tô te escutando
esse mundo até hoje
E aí
[Música]